It's week two
and it is Cake Week and...
Wow! Noel, that is amazing!
I love your commitment
to the theme of the week.
No, I mean... No, no,
don't have to explain.
I've totally got it.
You are Marie Antoinette,
because what is the one thing
that we all know about her?
That she famously said, "Let them
eat cake," and it's Cake Week.
I just...
I love that you've bothered.
I mean,
I don't want to nit-pick, you know,
cos historically probably
she never said it.
I think it's one of the great
misquotes of history.
If anything, she would have said,
"Let them eat brioche."
But chances are
she never even mentioned cake.
I mean,
people just said it about her
because, you know, they were mean.
But honestly, well done.
I don't know
what you're talking about.
These are the only clothes
I had left that were clean.
Clean is good.
Last time...
Come on, biscuits.
..Briony saw herself
rising to the top.
I love the balloons.
Can we eat a balloon? Please do.
But it was Manon...
I think you've done an amazing job.
Thank you.
..who was crowned this year's
first Star Baker.
And although Ruby crumbled...
I am losing it, Noel.
..it was Imelda...
Oh, sugar plum fairies!
..who was first to leave the tent.
Now it's Cake Week.
This is not going to go well.
The Signature Bake
sees temperatures rise...
Well, good luck cooling it.
..the bakers go green
for the Technical Challenge...
Urgh! The weirdest thing
I've ever done for a cake.
..and face
a chocolate Showstopper...
Lordy, Lordy. It's hot.
..on one of the hottest days...
# Under pressure! #
..the Bake Off tent has ever seen.
Whoa!
It's OK.
Cake Week.
Kind of looking forward to it
cos I've been practising
literally nonstop.
Best of luck.
Even though I'm a baker,
cakes are not really my thing.
So many things
that can go wrong with cake.
Pfft! Just trying not to think about
that right now.
I am going to run out of time today
so warning, spoiler alert.
Beep-beep-beep.
Hello, bakers.
Welcome to Cake Week
and your Signature Challenge.
Today, the judges
would like you to create
that classic crowd pleaser,
a traybake.
They want you
to TRAY and bake a cake.
That posh accent's
not working for you.
You can use any type of sponge,
any flavour,
but you must be able to make 16
identical slices from your traybake.
You've got two hours to complete
your Signature Challenge.
On your marks... ..get set..
..bake!
PRUE: A traybake, as the name
implies, is baked in a tray.
Generally, they're the good,
old reliable sponge cakes
with sort of white icing on top.
But I would like to see something
I've never seen before.
You've got to bite into it.
A little bit of crunch
on the top's nice.
Hit that beautiful sponge
and, of course, flavour -
they must get that flavour
across to us in a very small bite.
Time management is critical.
Get this wrong,
they're in a whole world of trouble.
Good morning, Antony. Hello, Paul.
Morning, Antony. Hello, Prue.
Hey, Noel.
Tell us about your traybake.
So it's a frangipane with a nice
sweet pastry, pineapple jam
and then a coconut burfi on top.
What is burfi?
It's like a coconut sweet, really.
Just milk powder,
desiccated coconut... Oh, delicious.
..and sugar.
Hi, Mama. How are you?
I'm very well.
Antony lives in London
but calls his mum, Maria,
back in Bangalore, every day.
How's the weather in Bangalore?
Oh, it's horrible.
Inspired by the burfi
he ate with his mum as a boy,
Antony's cardamom
frangipane traybake
blends Indian sweets
with classic British baking.
Sounds like a slightly different
Bakewell tart, doesn't it?
Yeah, it's like
an Indian Bakewell tart. Yeah.
I think you might have invented
something there. Yeah.
Briony is also attempting
to pull off a culture clash.
I've gone for Spanish flavours
because I'm a massive fan of Spain
and all things Spanish, so I wanted
to sort of incorporate that
into the good old British traybake.
Briony is currently training
for her third half marathon
with her cockapoo, Archie.
And the race is on to complete
her traybake
with an orange pastry base, almond
sponge and a chocolate ganache
on top of a soft Spanish nougat
called a turron.
Hola. Hola. Hola!
Hola! Que tal, Sandi?
Do you speak Spanish?
Si. Claro que si.
Do, do you really? Yes.
I studied it at university.
And your Danish? No.
Well, I'm going to...
I'm up for trying.
We've got time. Yeah, teach me.
You need actually, probably, to get
all the way through to the final,
I'm just saying, if I'm going to
teach you anything. Yeah. OK?
OK, here we go. Jeg er... Jeg er...
..konge i... ..konge i...
..Danmark. ..Danmark.
Og jeg... Og jeg...
..kan lide... ..kan lide...
..Jordbaer. ..Jordbaer.
Yeah. What did you just make me say?
"I am the king of Denmark
and I like strawberries."
And I think that is
going to see you though
any part of Denmark
that you wish to go to.
Come on.
Dan is also headed for Europe.
I'm just going to try not to panic,
cos it didn't serve me well
last time.
He's off to Germany via the 1970s.
It's a riff on
a Black Forest gateau.
Maybe they were trendy
when I was growing up,
but you don't see them
much these days.
Despite being too young
to remember the '70s,
as a boy, Black Forest gateau
was Dan's absolute favourite.
He's making a vanilla cream topping
and will decorate with
intricate tempered chocolate,
but he's already
discovered a problem.
I thought nobody else would do it
but, unfortunately...
Chocolate, cherries, cream,
is delicious.
..Ruby's stealing my ideas.
Oh! Whoa, whoa, whoa! Honestly!
Less of that
"stealing the idea" business!
Ruby's ideas in the kitchen
have usually been inspired
by her mum, Kalvinder.
Mmm. That's good. Got to say,
not as good as Mum's though.
Ruby made her Black Forest gateau
for her family last Christmas.
It has a dark chocolate ganache
and white chocolate drizzle
on top of a moist chocolate sponge.
I'm a bit worried because it's quite
a tender chocolate sponge. Yeah.
How are you going to get it
into neat slices?
The key thing for me
is to make sure that it's chilled,
otherwise it could turn
into a sloppy mess.
Yeah, no pressure.
When it comes
to her sponge recipe...
Un, deux, trois, quatre, cinq, six.
..last week's Star Baker, Manon,
has put herself
under even more pressure.
I'm not using any raising action.
I'm only using the egg whites,
actually are going
to make it fluffy.
So it's quite a lot of eggs.
CHICKENS CLUCK
When Manon left the family farm in
Brittany for London six years ago,
it awoke a passion
for British baking.
Ow!
Her raising agent-free traybake,
with rosemary, honey and fresh figs,
was one of the first recipes
she learnt in her adoptive home.
My first job in London, there's
a landlady where I used to work -
she made the best honey cake ever.
The risk is that it can not raise.
Terry is taking an even bigger risk
with his sponge batter.
What's this, then?
Er, this is just an apple sauce.
And where's that going?
Into my batter.
It's interesting
that you're using this
cos there's a lot of liquid
in apple.
It's a nice, moist cake
and it's actually it's better
a few days after you make it.
Terry also has the patience
to keep bees.
Looks like I've got a nice active
little queen in there.
Using their honey
to slowly brew his own beer.
Should be a nice, sweet mix.
There's an alcoholic kick
to his traybake,
with rum-soaked raisins and dates
being added to
his moist apple sponge.
Are we going to taste the rum?
You will.
There is a rum syrup that goes
on the top once the sponge is cool.
NOEL: A lot of rum?
Hopefully.
PRUE: I'm counting on it.
Some rum shots on the side?
I might. I might, yeah.
Just keep bringing the rum
and Prue will be happy.
Every minute
in the Signature Challenge...
Ooh. Ooh, ooh, ooh.
..is now precious.
I need to get this
into the oven, ASAP.
The longer the bakers'
large traybake-sized sponges
need in the oven...
Come on.
..the less time
they'll have to cool.
And now... waiting time.
And a warm cake
can't be sliced and decorated.
Doesn't that look delicious?
There we go.
That's going to be in there
for about 25 minutes.
This is going in for 35 minutes.
This needs 20 minutes.
It's quite a thin cake.
It's a very short bake time.
So it's got lots of time to cool.
TIMER BEEPS
Bake well, my love.
Now there's even more
to worry about.
Okey dokey.
The judges will be expecting
each traybake sponge
to be accompanied by complimentary
fillings and toppings.
This is Valencian orange jam
but they still a nice bitter taste.
You know when it's ready
when it hits when it hits 105.
Very helpfully,
it says "jam" on it, actually.
And it also says "hard crack"
on there as well.
I'm not sure what that, um,
temperature's for.
I am making my rosemary syrup.
I love rosemary.
You know, it reminds me
of Welsh lamb like, you know?
While I'm eating a lemon cake.
I think you should wear this one.
Jon also adds
an unconventional twist
to his job delivering blood
to the NHS
by letting his daughters,
Lucy and Hannah,
choose what he wears to work.
Why not this one?
Oh, that is very nice.
Your mother doesn't
like that one at all.
But Mum and the girls
have all approved
his Italian meringue-topped traybake
that pairs his favourite herb
with his favourite pudding.
I like lemon meringue pie,
so I thought I would try
a lemon meringue cake
rather than lemon meringue pie.
In the oven, I'm making
a pandan chiffon traybake cake.
And what's pandan?
So pandan is like a long leaf,
and you get the juice from it.
And does the pandan give colour
as well as flavour? Yes.
SHE LAUGHS
That's revolting.
LAUGHING: Do you know...?
Do you know what it's like?
NOEL: It's going well, I think.
It's like I just cut me lawn.
It's just like I cut me lawn.
Kim-Joy often bakes treats
for her and her partner Nabil's
marathon board game sessions.
Her pandan and coconut traybake,
topped with palm sugar cream,
is one of his favourites.
It's kind of a love
or hate flavour, so...
Isn't that a dangerous thing to do?
I love it, so...
I quite like it. Do you?
It's like pond water. Yeah, good...
I think that could be delicious.
Thanks.
Sort of reminding me of frog spawn.
Lovely.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
Wow, if we've got an hour we could
cut your hair using this bowl.
I'll take that.
There's a saying where I come from -
a watched pot never boils.
The bakers now face
a crucial decision.
I'm a bit scared
to look in the oven.
Cake's coming out in about a minute.
Take a traybake
out of the oven too soon
and the under-baked sponge
could collapse when it's cut.
Leave it too long,
and not only do they risk
running out of cooling time...
Oh, no. Definitely more time.
Yeah, that's done.
..but also tough, crumbly slices.
Let's just wait for it.
Omm.
Might have to whack the oven
temperature up a little bit, maybe.
In fact, I'm going to do that now.
Got about another
15, 20 minutes left yet.
HE SIGHS
Just a bit of a waiting game now.
Back home in Sheffield,
a bake in the oven means a chance
for Luke to take Ruby,
Oscar and Daisy
for one of their two walks
a day with his fiancee, Kelly.
You all right?
Yeah, I'm losing my jeans.
They often return to his classic
lemon and poppy seed traybake,
with a white chocolate
and mascarpone topping.
Not sure if it's cooked
in this little bit.
Yeah, there's this
one little section within it
that just doesn't want to bake.
Whilst most bakers have enough
to worry about with one sponge...
All right.
Ow!
..one has managed to make his
Signature Challenge twice as hard.
I don't really want to
over-bake them.
I don't want to under-bake
them either.
Rahul's planned a traybake
that's double layered.
I did quite a lot of experiment
with this recipe.
I baked it, like, five or six
different versions of it.
Rahul often gets
his best baking ideas
whilst working out at his local
leisure centre in Rotherham.
It's inspired a seventh version
of his double lemon
joconde sponge traybake,
with Italian meringue buttercream
and now a drizzle with the juice of
four lemons and 25 cardamom pods.
It just smell like, er, disinfectant
so don't worry about that.
SHE COUGHS
Wow! That's... strong.
Oh, my God.
So it does smell like disinfectant?
Well, I think
I certainly wouldn't mind
cleaning the corners of my fridge
with it. Oh, wow, great.
No, I'm sure
it will taste delicious.
Right. I'm going to go for it.
I think I'm going to take it out.
# Hallelujah! #
He is ginormous.
How thick is it? Mine's probably
going to be about that thick.
Oh, no, mine's like that.
Oh, mine's quite deep.
Well, good luck cooling it.
Oh, God!
With time running out...
Come on.
..the moment their sponges
are cool enough...
He's big.
..the bakers need to be ready
with all their fillings,
toppings and decorations.
Hopefully I'll squeeze it in,
in ten minutes.
Yeah, you know you're not
actually wearing a watch, right?
Just-just... that's not
really helping you.
Rum sauce. A tablespoon of rum in.
Just a little extra for Prue.
Hopefully she'll get the, um,
rum flavour from that.
Mixing together the honey and the
sugar and water for the turron.
My marmalade is simmering.
Ganache ganaching.
Maybe I've just done
too many things.
At the moment, I'm just piping
some chocolate shapes onto acetate,
and they will stand upright
on top of the cake.
I tried various things
for the topping, unsuccessfully,
and I wanted to use the marzipan and
I just got a flash of inspiration.
Just thought, "Edible food paint.
Metallic."
So it's beautiful and shiny.
Since recently becoming
a grandmother for the first time,
Karen has been devoting
her creative energies
into artistic bakes for her family.
Now then, this seal,
do they have legs?
No, they have flippers.
Her striped marzipan
will sit on an almond sponge
layered with a tart rhubarb jam.
I've done the stripy bits, although
I could titivate for a while,
but I'm just putting
some beautiful glitter on it.
Why wouldn't you?
Full disco.
Sandi, we need to do a time call.
Yeah, no, I'm skipping this one.
Bakers,
you only have 15 minutes remaining.
So that's a slight worry.
I shall have to
caramelise my nuts a bit quicker.
Now it's messy.
Turron can set quite quickly,
so I have to make that
kind of at the last minute.
Ooh, it's going to be
a rush at the end!
Pushing it a little bit.
Just putting my drizzle
into my cake.
I'm just spreading
my Italian meringue buttercream.
I'm reasonably happy.
I think Ruby's struggling
with cooling it down.
It's still way too hot.
Quite warm now, isn't it?
It is very warm.
Ah, cheers for that, Sandi.
Is that better? That's amazing.
Right, here we go. Turron on.
It's so sticky.
Mine's roasting.
This bad boy just needs to go
and chill in the fridge, though.
It's too hot. It's going to melt.
This is going to look a mess.
God, I've got to
get 16 pieces off this.
The judges have demanded
identical crisp, clean slices.
This is all about precision.
Hopefully get it looking
relatively even.
So I've divided in four,
and each four is going to be divided
into four more.
Un, deux, trois, quatre... Sorry.
So I need to do seize.
Urgh.
Oh, God. They're looking hot.
Some are a bit bigger than others.
Oops.
They look so messy and rubbish.
They might not be as finished
as I'd like them to be
but they'll be there.
It's hotting up.
So now the ganache is melting.
I'd like to take a bit more care
in doing this
but I just haven't got time
at the moment.
Bakers,
you have one minute remaining.
Oops.
Oh, you mucky pup.
Finished.
What a mess.
Bakers, your time is up.
Ugh. You're done. Done.
You're done. We're done.
Look at everyone's.
It's just pretty and pretty
and pretty. Pretty, pretty, pretty.
Oh, dear.
SANDI: It's judgment time for the
bakers' Signature traybakes.
Hello, Rahul. Hi.
They are quite elegant
and it reminds me of an afternoon
tea in a five-star hotel
cos they look like they're finger
sandwiches. Oh. Let's have a taste.
You certainly get the lemon and the
cardamom,
and they're in the right proportion.
I think that's very good.
For something that looks like
a wholemeal finger sandwich,
they taste beautiful. Sigh of
relief. Yeah. Thank you.
Cheers. Thanks.
It's quite a tough sponge.
And it's a bit bland as well. OK.
You really have got the balance
of the coconut and the frangipane
absolutely perfect. It's very
delicate. Not as powerful
as I thought it'd be. It is a little
bit of a mess... Thanks, Paul.
..but I think it's a pretty decent
traybake.
Tough as old boots.
And the top is very sloppy,
so you've got sloppy and tough.
Sounds like a terrible double act,
Sloppy And Tough.
You were right about the rum.
It's very rummy.
Because the amount of apple that
you've put in there,
it brings flavour. Blending that
with the raisin, the rum,
I think you have a beautiful,
traditional traybake.
Not very sophisticated
but a real pleasure to eat.
I think they look very elegant.
You have kept it simple...
Yes. ..but it is down
to that sponge.
I think the marzipan's a bit too
thick for that amount of sponge.
The sponge is very dry. That's
a shame, cos they look great.
Thank you very much for your
feedback. That's great. Thank you.
They look really elegant.
They look all the same size.
Very neat.
Oh, lovely colour.
I love that pale green.
That comes from the pandan
leaf, doesn't it? Yeah.
Mm. I love the chiffon.
That is lovely.
Textures are perfect.
The look of it's perfect.
But I just don't like the pandan.
No, I accept that.
Some people don't.
For me, it's not the right flavour
to go in a traybake, but I admire
the fact that you did it, because
that chiffon's perfect.
I hope, really hope they taste OK.
So do I, um, cos they look hideous.
I know! I know. I'm sorry.
It's divine. Is it? Oh.
There you go.
Honestly, I don't care the
way it looks. Really? Yeah.
I have to have another bite.
The almonds in there.
The turron as well.
The whole thing together.
The orange. It's delicious.
Absolutely lovely. Oh, thank you.
Can't believe I'm crying
over a traybake.
LAUGHTER
Well, I have to say they look
very elegant. Thank you.
I'm not quite sure I'd like a whole
piece of rosemary leaf in my mouth.
Right. But you've got chopped
rosemary inside, haven't you?
Yes. Yes.
I'll tell you what, it's delicious
when you do get a bit of rosemary.
The Italian meringue, it tastes
fine, it just needed more whipping.
Chocolate goes well with it as well.
Sponge is good, but it's down to
those little elegant touches
and I think you lost it slightly
with the Italian meringue.
Thank you.
It looks like a forest floor.
OK. It's a mess. It's broken apart
as you've tried to portion this,
cos some are thin, some are thick.
I think, as a chocolate cake goes,
it's fantastic. Yeah.
I mean, very, very good.
The biggest issue is that you
don't get any cherry.
Right, OK. Maybe more kirsch in
there would have helped as well.
Oh, I'm not sure about the kirsch
but I could eat that
with a great deal of pleasure,
though. Oh, good. Phew.
Well, the decoration
is absolutely excellent.
Everything is very neat.
You pipe very well.
It's not too thick. Impressive.
Thank you. I think they look
amazing. Good interior.
Mm. Nice and boozy.
Come on. Say something nice.
Like your T-shirt.
Just doing my best here.
That'll do. Oh, wow.
APPLAUSE
Thank you very much.
What I liked about it,
it looks incredible.
But, when you get inside,
and you do hit that cherry
and the kirsch sits there,
and then the topping,
it's just a really nice cake.
I could sit and eat the whole lot.
He's blushing.
He's actually blushing. I am.
I thought he was joking.
I was waiting for him to go...
"Just kidding!"
And I said I wouldn't cry,
and I did cry.
They were tears of happiness,
though.
I was always expecting Paul to have
a gripe but "forest floor"?
He is savage.
NOEL: The bakers were able to
practise their traybakes
but, with ingredients
shrouded in gingham,
the cake they'll take on next
is a total mystery.
Right, bakers,
time for your Technical Challenge,
which today has been set
for you by Prue.
Any words of advice?
Go like the clappers.
You don't have much time.
Wow. That's made everybody
feel good, right?
Off you two go, and carry on with
your extreme ironing,
whatever you're doing.
For your Technical Challenge today,
Prue would like you to make
an impression of a cake.
Quite literally.
It's her version of the
Impressionist painter
Claude Monet's favourite birthday
treat, Le Gateau Vert.
You need to make a light, delicate
pistachio, genoise sponge.
Green. Mm-hm.
Sandwiched with a pistachio
creme au beurre. More green.
And covered in a fondant
coloured green with? Spinach?
Yes. That's a complete fluke.
You have two and a quarter hours.
On your marks... ..Get set...
..Bake!
Oh, there's actually spinach.
I thought he was joking.
For the Technical Challenge, the
bakers have identical ingredients...
This is absolutely ridiculous.
..and Prue's pared-down recipe.
In shock.
I don't even know what I'm making.
PAUL: Prue. Gateau Vert.
Claude Monet cake.
What on earth are you thinking?
One of the reasons I really love
this cake is because not only
was it one of Claude Monet's
favourite cakes but he had it
every year on his birthday.
So, how does it get that
beautiful green colour?
It's some spinach puree.
The thicker the puree, the more
green you can get into the fondant.
Those layers look amazing.
The most usual problem with a
genoise is not getting the volume.
It has to be at least an inch and
a bit, so that you can cut it
into three and it'll be light
and delicious. That is beautiful.
This is about the basics being done
well and I think at this
early stage, it's a fantastic
challenge.
The person who keeps their head will
do the best because
there's a real danger of panicking
when you see how much
you've got to do.
If Prue Leith tells you've got to
hurry, I guess that means
you've got to hurry. "Make the
genoise sponge". OK.
It's actually my favourite
sponge to make. Fingers crossed.
"Place the sugar and eggs
in a large bowl".
You have to whisk it for quite a
high speed, for quite a long time.
All of the lift comes just from
whisking the eggs.
So, that's going to be
the tricky bit.
I'm just going to time it,
how long I'm going to whisk it.
I think I'll say about
eight minutes.
Fold in pistachios and flour
mixture, butter and lemon zest.
Don't want to knock out
any of the air.
What I take now is a little bit of
the genoise and mix it in
with the butter cos then I find it
easier to fold it
into the rest of it. I'm just a bit
concerned about this.
Oh, I know what I've done wrong.
It seems I should have done
something with this and I
didn't and I don't know whether I
should have separated the eggs.
This is not going to go well.
But Karen isn't the only baker
struggling.
I should have done the whites
separately, I think.
Softly. Gently.
It's a question of whether I just
abandon ship or go back.
I'm going to go with it.
I'm trying again.
So, start from the beginning.
It just says "bake".
For... I don't know. It just says,
"bake".
I'm baking for ten minutes
initially, then I'll check on it.
I think it'll be about 15.
Just going for unlucky 13.
I'm sure it'll need at
least 20 minutes.
Let's come back in 20.
18 minutes.
SANDI: Right, bakers, that's
half an hour gone.
So, that'll be like a biscuit.
Sandi, that was magnificent.
Thanks, Noel. I mean, I'm not
actually meant to be here.
I just love watching you work.
I know. Thank you so much. OK.
So, now I'm going to make
the marzipan.
"Finely grind the pistachios".
Add the icing sugar and combine.
No-one got time to be making
marzipan.
You just go and buy it.
I've made marzipan before.
"Add the egg whites
and pistachio essence.
"Knead until smooth, wrap in
clingfilm and leave to rest".
I actually quite liked Monet,
as well, before this.
Do you like Monet, though?
Um, I'm not sure who he is.
I know Monet but I've never
seen this cake.
He did the water lilies. Yeah.
Right.
Do you like van Gogh?
You know van Gogh. Yeah.
Done his ear in, didn't he, you
know? One ear.
My cake does not look right at all.
Oh, it's pretty poor.
I don't want to be scolded for
baking, after this morning
saying I had tough-as-old-boots
sponge, I don't want to do it again.
Oh, my God, his looks so good.
I think I would go with that.
It's come out how I expected
it to come out.
Looking like a cake. You have
totally nailed how Bake Off works.
It hasn't risen.
But anyway...
Oh, mate, this is a disaster.
It's sunk.
Nope.
I don't know whether to start again.
I'm making the cake again.
Like, I've got a flat one and I can
always use that
in an emergency
but I need another one.
Started my sponge again.
Oh, God.
"Make la creme au beurre".
Creme au beurre, is,
well, buttercream, basically.
"Add the spinach
and cook until wilted".
SANDI: The colours in a Gateau
Vert...
..are all natural. Oh, man.
Oh, look at that. Look at that.
That is green, isn't it?
It's quite weird cos we're making
cake but it smells like...
And it smells like... ..weird...
..smells like health, doesn't it?
..boiled cabbage.
SANDI: Unless the bakers ensure
they squeeze
every drop of water
from their pureed spinach...
Let's see how much it is
at the moment.
..their creme au beurre
and fondant topping...
Oh. ..won't have the vivid green
appearance that Monet loved.
Urgh. OK, yeah, that's the weirdest
thing I've ever done for a cake.
That's a full sack.
Spinach-flavoured creme au beurre.
Conscience is saying - that's not
good.
I hope this one works, cos I
definitely won't have a chance
to do this one again.
This time, I've beaten my
egg whites first.
As Dan and Terry begin baking
a second genoise sponge...
See how we get on with that.
..the rest of the bakers need to cut
theirs into three equal layers.
How anybody's going to slice that
into three is anybody's guess.
When I'm doing this, I can
see where I'm at.
My knife skills are pretty
questionable.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
OK, we've got one layer.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
That is bad. Very bad.
Second time round, I would have
preferred a bigger rise
on the sponge but - hey.
Starting again.
Everyone must be looking at me -
"Has he lost the plot?"
Oh, there's so much to do.
SANDI: Bakers,
you have half an hour remaining!
That was the best
time call of the year. Oh, thanks.
Actually sorry, second best.
Going to have to take that back.
Wow. I had an acceptance speech
and everything, ready.
That's the most gracious
defeat of the year.
Oh, thanks so much. Sorry, second.
Second place.
I would have liked to have spent
a bit more time prepping it
and folding it all together but,
just, time's not on my side.
"Sandwich together with the
creme au beurre".
So, you're looking for that
silky texture.
That is absolute liquid.
That's very thin towards the end.
Cover the top and the sides of the
sponge with marzipan.
I made marzipan.
Oh, come on.
Please just do it and be cooked.
Keen to get this excess off
cos it's weighing it down.
Quite pleased with
the marzipan, actually.
It's, uh, looking all right.
NOEL: Bakers, you have five minutes
left.
Right, this is coming out.
I don't think it's any better
than the other one.
Right, what's next?
"Coat the cake with the icing".
It looks pretty green, isn't it?
I'm just choosing the best bits
from, like, the sponges I've made.
We'll cheat a bit.
Oh, God. Such a mess.
Starting to come together a bit now.
Finally.
Says, "Elegantly decorate
with chopped pistachios
"and edible flowers".
Can't believe I've managed to do
this, to be honest.
NOEL: Bakers, your time is up.
I'm walking away.
It's a little ring of
beauty, isn't it?
It looks like something.
SANDI: Please place your Gateau Vert
behind your photograph on the table.
Paul and Prue are expecting Gateau
Vert with three even layers
of pistachio genoise sponge,
pistachio marzipan,
and spinach-coloured fondant
and creme au beurre.
And they won't know whose is whose.
Right, shall we start with this one?
Lovely colour.
It's got a nice colour, hasn't it?
That looks like the proper layers.
That's a nice cake. Delicious,
isn't it? The creme au beurre
and the genoise are fantastic.
The pistachio comes through.
Now, the colour's all wrong on this.
The layers aren't too bad.
Nice flavour. Moving on.
Now, it's lost all the height,
hasn't it? Yeah.
Looks quite wet as well.
It's a bit puddingy, to be honest.
OK, moving on. Nice colour.
It is.
That is very nice.
It does taste good.
It's quite a rounded cake.
How have they achieved that?
The layers aren't too bad.
Flavour's OK. The filling's good and
the sponge is all right.
Now, this one looks quite nice
when you initially look at it.
The layers are equal.
The flavour's all right. Mm. Mm.
You seem to have lost a couple of
the layers here.
The creme au beurre,
seem to have lost some of it.
It's quite stodgy, isn't it?
I think it's a bit overcooked.
OK. I worry about this one.
First of all, it's very thin.
They've knocked all the air out
the genoise and the colour's wrong.
Where are the layers?
Very rubbery,
undercooked cake.
That's sad.
I quite like the look of this.
I do, too. It's very pretty.
The cake looks very good.
Tastes of pistachio.
Really beautiful sponge.
I quite like this one as well.
It's got a bit of height to it.
That's a lot of icing on there.
The cake is lovely.
Right, moving on to the last one.
This looks bone-dry on the side,
with a flooding of fondant on the
top. It is. And it's...
It's a bit of a mess.
..over-decorated. Yeah, it is.
The sponge is quite light.
Though not very high.
NOEL: Prue and Paul will now rank
the cakes from worst to best.
In 11th place, we have this one.
Karen.
You know what's the matter with it,
it wasn't cooked.
In tenth is this one.
Quite stodgy inside, actually.
NOEL: In ninth place, it's Antony.
Terry is eighth.
Seventh is Luke.
Manon is sixth.
Briony fifth.
And Kim-Joy is fourth.
In third place we have this one.
Dan, it looks lovely
and it tasted great.
So, in second spot...
..is this one. Whose is this?
Pretty good, Rahul.
Nice cake. Well done.
Which means, number one, we have
Jon.
Yes. There's nothing to say about
this, it's just a lovely cake.
Thank you. Cheers.
APPLAUSE
That was amazing. Absolutely spot
on. That is up there.
Birth of the kids, wedding day,
and that. That's there.
Well done, mate. Oh, yeah,
definitely.
Yeah, it's OK.
I'm just quite scared about
what's coming next.
It was technical and it was
a challenge. So... yes.
What I always do, when I have
a disappointment, is sort of
crash down like this and, normally,
within a short space of time,
I bounce straight back again.
So, watch this space for tomorrow.
Yeah.
Just the Showstopper Challenge
remains before we discover who
will be our second Star Baker and
who'll be leaving the Bake Off tent.
Coming into the Showstopper
I think Dan's done well.
First handshake. He is in line for
Star Baker, along with Jon.
Rahul has been
consistently near the top.
Some people need to fight to
stay in the Bake Off
and I would include Manon in there.
This is shocking.
Terry has to be in there
as well, and Karen.
Her gateau vert was
a complete disaster.
And likewise, Luke struggled
in the Signature and
didn't do particularly well either
in the Technical.
And I would include Ruby in that.
You said her traybake looked
like a forest floor. It did.
The Showstopper today
involves chocolate.
And it's going to be
extremely hot today.
It's going to be a very challenging
last bake for somebody.
Too hot for a Goth.
I'll probably melt.
Hello, bakers,
time for your Showstopper Challenge.
Paul and Prue would love you to make
a chocolate collar cake.
The cake can be any flavour
that you like
but it must be at least two tiers,
encased in chocolate that wraps
all the way around the cake,
hence the name chocolate collar.
The design must be eye-catching and,
of course, the cake must be delish.
You have four hours.
On your marks...
..get set...
..bake.
Good Lord, I am roasting.
It's much hotter than chocolate
likes to be.
It's one thing to make a cake
but unless you're a chocolatier,
you are not likely to make
a chocolate collar.
Now, the chocolate collar itself
is all about the tempering of
the chocolate, setting it on acetate
and then placing it around
the cake of their choice. You have
to be part architect on this.
Nobody in their right mind would be
dealing with chocolate
on a day like today,
but this is Bake Off
and they're going to have to.
Hello, Jon, you all right?
How are you all, all right?
Well, that looks like
pineapple cake.
I'm doing a pina colada cake
cos I like pina colada and
getting caught in the rain.
Jon's pineapple sponge with coconut
buttercream will be wrapped
in a collar, which should bring
his tropical Showstopper together.
My collar is a Hawaiian shirt
going round the outside.
I can't think how you
thought of it, Jon!
Well, where would that come from?
Out of the top of my head
or out of my wardrobe. Either one.
Antony has also raided
the wardrobe for inspiration.
The collar is a sari,
which is worn by most Indian women.
Let's hope I get it down to the tee.
His sari collar will wrap pistachio
and rose water sponge
with saffron buttercream.
The flavours are my mum's
favourite flavours,
so it is a dedication to her.
My mum doesn't like chocolate,
so my sponge is orange
and the cream is chocolate.
Ruby's future in the Bake Off
rests on
her mum's favourite
orange liqueur sponge...
Just a splash.
..sandwiched with a chocolate
mascarpone and hazelnut cream,
all wrapped in a collar straight
from the walls of an art gallery.
My collar is inspired
by Jackson Pollock.
Some might just say it's a mess.
Some might say that's very strategic
of me, to have a messy collar.
The judges have demanded the bakers
wrap collars around at least
two tiers of delicious sponge.
It's going to be chocolate cake,
salted caramel cake,
chocolate cake, and there'll be
three tiers of that.
And while some are going
above and beyond,
hoping to avoid an early exit...
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, um.
..Terry is aiming even higher.
My chocolate collar cake is
going to be the Eiffel Tower.
Two tiers of sponge and then
a lace chocolate topping.
That's quite brave. Yeah.
Have you practised in heat?
I've practised in heat.
I've had my central heating
whacked up to 80 degrees,
working in the kitchen
with the oven on.
I hate to see my bill
when it comes through!
Terry's tower will rest on white
chocolate sponge filled with
champagne buttercream and topped
with strawberries.
It's a very summery
sort of flavoured sponge,
and strawberries, champagne, Paris -
you can't go wrong.
All right, Tez.
Oh!
TERRY LAUGHS
Oh, perfect Paris, Marie Antoinette.
Exactly. All right? Yeah.
Made a big sacrifice.
You better win.
This is what I do for you kids,
all right?
So make it count in the baking.
That is quite a costume.
I'm going in the oven.
Ah!
The bakers now face an epic test of
their ability to multitask.
Bake, angels, bake.
With several
different-sized sponges...
So, I'm going to put this little one
here so I can keep an eye.
..they'll have to keep track of
multiple baking times...
Six inches will take
about 45 minutes.
Uh, eight inches will take
about an hour.
..whilst at the same time prepare
their show-stopping fillings
and decorations.
I'm trying to do a chocolate sail,
if possible.
So that's why I'm making
two instead of one.
If one fails, then at least I have
something to put it on the top.
Rahul's sail will join chocolate
shards and an ornate
Bengali-inspired collar,
wrapping triple-layered chocolate
and orange sponges with
a white chocolate Swiss meringue.
You're doing creme au beurre,
Swiss meringue buttercream,
your collars...
I'm doing a lot.
..two different types of sponges.
I'm literally running
around like a headless chicken now.
So I'm just going to do it
a little bit early and then put it
in the fridge for a bit
just to set it a bit.
But I quite like Swiss meringue
buttercream because
it's quite good to do the coating,
and creme au beurre is quite,
like, similar, so it's very good
to stack things up together.
So that's why I'm doing
two buttercreams.
But if I run out of time
I might have no creme au beurre,
just do everything with
Swiss meringue buttercream.
Very succinctly put.
Thank you very much indeed. Sorry.
Look forward to it. Cheers.
Kim-Joy's Showstopper...
Brrrrr.
..is a little more focused.
They're just, like,
little cat silhouettes,
cos I thought it'd look
kind of fun, like,
with them playing all around it.
Her cats will chase a ribbon around
a white chocolate collar that
surrounds genoise sponge filled
with yuzu curd and topped with
even more cats made with fondant.
I think I get a lot of
influences from Japan.
Also kind of makes sense because,
like, cats wear collars, don't they?
So let's hope it's not
a CAT-astrophe.
After a disappointing first day,
a catastrophic Showstopper
isn't an option for Manon.
So when I was an au pair,
I used to look after a little girl
that I used to love dressing up
as a princess,
so this cake is for her.
She's aiming for a fairy-tale ending
to Cake Week with a fondant
princess and prince for
an almond castle cake wrapped in
a crown of white chocolate
and dark chocolate ramparts.
Sandi's had an accident.
Sandi, get up! It's OK.
That's fantastic.
Is that me and Sandi?
Yeah, well, that's you fast asleep
and that's Sandi,
she's BLEEP off because you're late.
Uh, I think...
I don't think you can say that.
You've been looking
at the wrong script.
90 minutes remaining.
I think it needs a few more minutes.
I don't want to bother them
for too long.
It doesn't look that bad.
It actually... I think it's cooked.
Woof.
They've risen a lot better
than the one at home.
They'll need about another
ten minutes or so.
Just going to get these bad boys out
and onto a cooling rack.
Whoa!
Oh...
Oh, no.
Stodgy-slash-raw.
Even though it was in there longer
than it would be in my oven at home.
Yeah, that's just raw. Oh!
Briony needs to bake three tiers of
chocolate fudge
and salted caramel cake
and fill them with
salted caramel vodka buttercream,
and she plans to wrap them in
a dark chocolate collar
with peanut butter brushstrokes.
I can't serve them raw cake.
That's just not happening.
I'll just have to remake it.
Where's my recipe gone?
Right, take a breath.
Take a breath.
It's looking OK. That one is,
but the other one is looking
very dubious.
Before they can wrap a collar
around their cakes...
They feel nice and bouncy.
..the bakers will need to cover the
rough edges of their cooled sponges.
Oh, I'm just trying to make
the creme au beurre.
I have a lot going on, as usual.
All right, we're now tipping on
some really good saffron.
Smells delicious.
But while most bakers are making
a flavoured buttercream for
their crumb coat, Luke has chosen
a more luxurious approach.
Just whipping the double cream
together now.
I'm doing the last bit by hand
cos it can all of a sudden
just over-whip.
He's making a whipped double cream
and white chocolate crumb coat
for a triple-tiered raspberry
and white chocolate cake
which he'll wrap
in an Art Deco collar.
I've now folded in
the white chocolate.
It needs to cool a bit,
cos in this temperature
it's just going to not get on well.
Bakers, you have one hour.
Just one hour.
Argh!
They're still warm. In an ideal
world, you would never do this.
He is a biggie.
Going to start with the smallest
tier and then work my way up,
cos obviously the other ones
are still in the oven.
I'm just concerned that
the buttercream is melting
as it goes on the cake.
It's quite runny. Ah!
My buttercream is just wilting.
Trying to get this neater.
Oh, it's just melting like crazy.
This is awful.
Time is running away fast.
But avoiding molten crumb coats
is just the first battle
in the bakers' war against the heat.
Absolute nightmare.
Oh, Lordy, Lordy, it's hot.
Tempering the chocolate is going to
be the most difficult bit in terms
of the conditions that we're in.
Yeah, so you basically want to
heat it up
and then almost cool it back down.
There's more to it than that,
I'm not saying I know everything
about chocolate tempering.
Bring it up to 38 degrees
and then...
No, bring it up to 43 degrees and
then bring it down...
..to 40... 30, I think.
Basically, chocolate has different
types of crystals in it.
So what you do is when you heat
the chocolate, they kind of
break down all the crystals,
and then you cool it quickly
so that some crystals
start forming again.
It sounds a bit funny, doesn't it?
Basically, when you get your
chocolates in the chocolate shop
and they've got a lovely gloss
on them, that's tempered chocolate.
Karen's tempering dark chocolate
to wrap two tiers of
rich chocolate cake filled with
strawberry jam and soaked in
a home-made strawberry liqueur.
But staying in the competition
may depend on her
successfully decorating her collar
with hand-piped lyrics
from a fitting folk song.
# As I was going to Strawberry Fair
# Singing, singing
buttercups and daises
# I met a maiden selling her wares
Fol-de-dee. #
It's basically about a prostitute,
right?
No, it's about a young lady
that meets a young suitor
and she tempts him with her wares...
Her wares?
..on her way to Strawberry Fair.
Dan's collar decoration will be
a little less freehand.
I've done it twice in practice.
I don't do things timed.
I can't get four hours of
undisturbed time in my house,
so I don't actually do it
against the clock.
Dan still needs to cover his
red-coloured white chocolate stripes
in dark chocolate for
a collar to surround chocolate
and raspberry cakes with raspberry
Italian meringue buttercream.
Hopefully there'll be enough
of a pattern in that one,
cos I can't wait any longer.
How long have we got left?
Bakers, you have half an hour.
30 minutes left.
I'm just going to have to
chill this fast.
Wow. I'm happy with this one.
It's way too hot to be cutting it
but don't have time to mess around.
This is the worst day ever
for doing chocolate.
# I like pina colada. #
My hand's wobbling really badly.
So I'm going to put
the white chocolate in between,
but obviously need to be quite
careful with the temperatures.
There's something about a sari
that's just extremely beautiful.
India's all about
the colour and the drama.
Yay!
So I don't want too many wrinkles
or anything that's going to distort.
Jackson Pollock would just probably
whack it on but in the same breath,
he's not being judged.
Bakers, you have ten minutes.
Is that right?
At home, five minutes,
the chocolate is set.
Here...
Oh, no, it's melting.
I have just got to get it
round the cake.
Just going to put this as well...
You need to just gauge it,
because if you leave it too long
it's not flexible.
You've only got a few minutes,
really, in which to get it on.
Oh.
Oh, it's way too stiff now.
I wussed out.
Solidly wussed out there.
Making sure that they are OK.
I just need to commit
and just do it.
Allez.
Just commit.
Just going to go with it.
This just acts as setting spray.
Just breathe.
It just won't go on.
It's just wet.
It shouldn't be like this at all.
Now it's going to go in the fridge.
# Say a little prayer for me! #
It's not gone to plan.
I've really messed up.
How many minutes do we have left?
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
If you were going to panic,
now's the time.
# Under pressure! #
I'm not happy with that.
It's going to cool it.
Oh, it's just all
completely melted.
It hasn't set because
it was too hot.
It's not set. My hands are so warm
as well, I can't even touch it.
The bottom collar
I just didn't have time to remake.
Oh, it's soft.
It's just absolutely...
I'm just going to leave it on.
It just didn't set.
Well...
That is just unbelievably bad.
Whoa!
Bakers, your time is up.
Gone.
Please step away from your
chocolate collar cakes.
I mean, it would be really
nice if the bottom one
had a chocolate collar on it.
Paul and Prue will be saying,
"I thought this was Art Deco."
More like art nightmare.
SHE SNIFFS
Are you all right? You OK?
What happened?
I just... I can't take the acetate
up.
It's not setting.
It's judgment time for
the bakers' Showstoppers.
Dan, would you like to bring
your Showstopper up, please?
I'm really impressed
because, with this heat, to get a
collar round it at all is an event.
I think you've done an amazing job
and the stripes are beautiful.
Well, that's beautiful.
It's rich and moist.
It's delicious.
The Swiss meringue with the
raspberries is bringing a tartness.
Married with the chocolate and the
collar, that's mighty impressive.
Well done, Dan. Thank you.
I'm really impressed
with the cats. They make you smile.
Better taste as good as it looks.
The sponge is quite firm.
It is slightly too dry.
It looks fantastic.
I do like the colours.
Wow. Wow.
The colours are just amazing.
I'm not getting pistachio.
There is no pistachio to blend
with the saffron.
It's just saffron in my mouth,
so it tastes almost savoury.
I think it looks amazing.
I love the piping.
The sheen you've got on the
chocolate is very good.
The collar's very neat.
That is really lovely
chocolate cake.
It melts in the mouth,
which is perfect. Fair play to you.
That's a great job.
Well, that's great to hear.
Thank you so much. I can't fault it.
It's simple and highly effective.
You've got a great sheen
on that chocolate.
I think it looks amazing.
It is tender. The pineapple
has made it very moist.
I think the sponge is fantastically
baked, and the coconut
really works with it as well.
And I really love your design.
Very good.
Well done. Thank you very much.
Cheers.
Luke, would you like to bring up
your Showstopper, please?
Not really!
Sorry about that.
Cream in this sort of heat...
Yeah.
..white chocolate in this sort of
heat. Let's see what it tastes like.
It might taste wonderful.
HE SIGHS
The flavour is delicious
but the cake is tough.
I'll eat the raspberries and cream
all day,
especially with the white chocolate.
Your sponge isn't good.
Is it not good?
It's a nice-looking sponge.
What's going on?
Why wasn't this taken off?
Basically, my chocolate didn't set.
Well, it's set now.
And, now it's off, this chocolate
is beautifully tempered
and absolutely shining.
OK.
That's a very nice sponge.
I think it's a very, very nice cake.
Very smart. Thank you.
It's a shame you didn't
take the acetate off!
LAUGHTER
Well, I have to say,
I think the way you've done
the ironwork is brilliant.
It may only be half the Eiffel Tower
but everybody knows what it is.
Yes. OK.
What I'm mostly getting is the
sweetness of the buttercream,
and the cake is a bit boring.
Bad luck, Terry. No problem.
Thank you, Terry. You're welcome.
We only asked you for two tiers...
Yes. I know. I know. ..so you did
get the collar around two. Yes.
We'll have a look
at your sponge now.
PAUL LAUGHS
Oh, look at that.
That is very beautiful.
Thank you.
Your sponge is overbaked.
You can see by the colour on the
outside how dark that is,
and the others are like rubber.
I agree with you that the textures
of the cake are not right
but I think the flavours are lovely.
OK. Thank you.
Wow. It's a wonderful construction.
I'm really impressed that you
managed to keep it together
and it hasn't all fallen down.
Based on the weather today
and the heat,
I think you've done
an unbelievable job.
Not just to do two collars but to do
this little pipework
across the top as well and then
do the shards on top of that.
I'm impressed, Rahul.
Thank you.
You can hear that crack.
It's beautiful.
Very bold, strong colours.
Fantastic.
Rahul, can you come here
a minute, please?
HE GASPS
I've never given a handshake
for a Showstopper before.
Thank you.
That is a fantastic cake.
Well done, Rahul. Well done, Rahul.
It really is very elegant and
very restrained.
Thank you. It's classy.
I can just tell by the way you're
cutting it that the sponge is
beautifully cooked.
I can sit here eating this
for an hour or so. Oh!
Phew. It's just delicious.
Thank you. Come here, Ruby.
SHOUTS OF ENCOURAGEMENT
Yes! Yes! Yes!
That cake,
that sponge, the flavour in there...
The hazelnut and the chocolate...
Every element comes through
perfectly.
The collar is so elegant.
The brittle on the top...
That's a fine cake.
Oh, thank you. Oh, I'm made up.
When Prue said that
she could sit there
and eat my cake all day long...
..buzzing.
I'm really happy with
Paul's handshake.
Would never take that back now.
Like, I'm pleased that one's
in the bag but...
..I wanted to impress Prue.
Good job. Yay. Amazing.
When Paul invited me to the table,
I just first thought that maybe
I have left something stupid inside
the cake, you know, like,
I was poking it with
a cocktail stick.
Maybe I left a cocktail stick
inside, so he wanted to show me.
Yeah, that was very surreal.
There weren't any surprises. No.
I'm surprised they even wanted
to judge it, to be honest.
You know it's only a cake.
The logical side of you knows
it's only a cake and,
at the end of the day,
it's not the end of the world.
It weren't as bad as mine, at least.
Look at it that way.
At least you had a collar on it!
Prue and Paul must now decide
who will be our second Star Baker
and who will have to leave
the Bake Off tent.
It was an extraordinary day,
because we went in very clear about
the people who were in trouble,
and all that has changed.
I was so pleased
with Ruby and Karen,
because they looked in such trouble.
And Manon. I think those three
people saved themselves.
I think we've got Luke and Terry
down at the bottom.
Yeah, and they didn't even look
good, did they?
Briony's Showstopper
wasn't particularly good.
She let herself down.
She's better than that.
The cake was stodgy.
I think when you're looking
at Star Baker,
Jon did a great job with
his pineapple cake,
I think Rahul's done a fantastic
job, and I also feel like
Dan has been probably the most
consistent throughout all.
Absolutely steady.
NOEL: Quite amazing that
two handshakes happened.
I've never given a handshake
on a Showstopper before,
but to give two...
I'm disappointed with myself!
But it...
The only... The only reason...
We're disappointed with you, too.
I know. Yeah.
Bakers, what a tremendous,
cake-fuelled weekend we have had,
and I have the pleasure of
announcing the Star Baker.
The person who is this week's
Star Baker made a giant of
a tray bake, has been
technically consistent,
and persuaded Paul
to give his first-ever handshake
in a Showstopper.
Rahul!
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Unfortunately, that means I get
to deliver the bad news.
The person who's leaving us
this week is...
..Luke.
I know, I know.
It wasn't my weekend, hey?
I'm just going to, like,
really miss everybody here.
Oh, mate, mate! I've lost my mate!
I just can't believe I've even made
it onto the show in the first place.
Just little old me, who just, like,
bakes in his kitchen,
started with his nan,
taught himself.
But, hey, I was still in the Bake
Off, I still went in the tent,
I still had Paul and Prue try food
I've baked,
which is, like, literally,
a dream of mine.
Next week, next week? I know,
next week, I will. Thank you.
I am so relieved to still be here.
I'm not going to cry!
I'm not going to cry.
Nope.
No, I'm not!
Still here, Terry.
Still here. Still in shock, I think.
It's a bit surreal, actually,
how much you do want it.
I will return home tomorrow
and practise, practise, practise!
Well done, Rahul.
You can cheer up now.
Yeah, I will try, yeah. Thank you.
All right? Yeah, yeah. I just...
Yeah, my emotions just go
a little bit crazy.
It feels so surreal.
Hollywood handshake
and the Star Baker...
Well done!
I just hope I didn't peak too early.
Next time...
TIMER BEEPS
And we're off.
..it's Bread Week...
Oh! Come on, bread.
Don't let me down.
..and Paul's not taking any
prisoners...
Makes me nervous.
..with a fruity classic
Signature Bake...
Do you want to see my buns?
THEY LAUGH
..a heated Technical Challenge
that's a British
takeaway favourite...
I genuinely have no idea. Agh!
..and show-stopping sweet breads
that are the largest ever baked
in the tent.
It is a big waiting game, but it's
worth it, you see? Worth it.
For subtitling services, contatct:
waqas.zahoor89@gmail.com
Subtitles by Red Bee Media